South Carolina has joined other
republican-led states across the south
in passing tighter abortion restrictions
the state senate approved a six-week ban
last night the governor has promised to
sign it as soon as possible Caitlin Huey
Burns is at the State House in Columbia
South Carolina and joins us now Caitlin
good morning
good morning to you Dana well this comes
after months of wrangling and failed
attempts and once this is signed into
law it will have wide implications for
abortion access in the South with
Virginia being the only remaining state
in the region without new restrictions
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade this bill would ban most abortions
after six weeks of pregnancy before most
women even know they were pregnant the
bill includes exceptions for rape and
incest through 12 weeks and also
includes exceptions for the life of the
mother and fatal fetal anomalies the
bill faced stiff opposition from the
Senate's five female members three of
them Republicans who had successfully
blocked a previous near total ban on
abortion before but this time around
they lost the support of three fellow
Republican men and this comes just one
week after Republicans and neighboring
North Carolina overruled the governor
there to pass a 12-week ban now this is
expected to face legal challenges back
in January the state supreme court
overturned this similar provision but
since then the Court's only woman has
since retired which changes the makeup
of the court and Republicans here think
that this new version will likely pass
Vlad
Caitlin Huey Burns reporting for us for
from South Carolina Caitlin thank you